well i'm on the roof of the globe
theater overlooking the river thames
having launched
the biggest uh domestic campaign for
tourism london's
ever seen but look as recently as five
years ago
london had a conservative mayor so we
know that over the last 21 years the
tories have either won this seat
or come second so we're incredibly
pleased and proud and feel privileged
that londoners have given me a big
mandate for a second term i'm looking
forward to
serving that second term right i do want
to get onto the labor party later but i
do also want to talk about opening up
london i think that's one of the reasons
why you've gone
to the globe theatre i mean at the
moment as you know
cinemas the west end tourism
are not happening in london how soon
will they be able to start again
from next monday and so the good news is
the prime minister will be announcing
today
further stages in the uh roadmap we've
begun a campaign
today let's do london it's the biggest
as i said
uh domestic uh tourism campaign has ever
seen
i was here with some great actors on the
stage of the globe
we're gonna have over the course of the
next few weeks and months amazing events
taking place in the heart of
our capital city from great chefs
from great artists from public arts
installations
from great events at theaters we've got
the euro 2020s delayed by year
coming to london eight games now at
wembley england may finally
bring it home other great things happen
in the western the good thing this year
the only silver lining by the lack of
international tourists
is for those londoners and those across
the country who want to come to london
hopefully
fewer people in queues so you can really
enjoy london in a way you couldn't
otherwise do
yeah but what are the arrangements going
to be i mean are we going to see
theaters and stadiums at capacity or
people still going to have to
be socially distanced are they going to
have to produce
evidence of having been vaccinated
what's going to happen
no in the short term there'll be some
staggering of start times and staggering
of leave times
there may in some place not be intervals
but no
no need for testing to take place and
stuff the good news is
because of the huge sacrifices
everyone's made across the country
we're making really good progress on the
virus going down the yard number
continues to
be doing well the vaccine roller
continues to go well
everyone should regularly test you can
now get free test kits
from your pharmacy or by going to the
relevant
web page it's really important we
continue to make progress
follow the advice that we're given the
prime minister's announcement today will
continue to bode well
for us to finally come out of this on
the 21st of june properly
but it's going to be great summer it's
going to be a great summer in london so
the fact you can't go overseas don't
worry you can come to
london and that's what let's do london
is all about
and uh there's talk about bringing the
big british-only
european football final to uh london
rather than holding it in turkey
are you involved in those discussions
and will you able be able to give uae
for the sort of wave as it wants
absolutely we've been speaking to the fa
and uaf we've got great relations with
uefa and the fa because of
our work with the euro 2020s which has
been delayed by year
we're ready and waiting for me doesn't
make sense for
chelsea fans man city fans to travel to
a red list country they shouldn't be
traveling but also rather than
there being an empty stadium we could
have thousands of fans safely watching
the team they love
this would be historic champion league
final city versus chelsea
city of uh could potentially win their
first champions league at chelsea their
second one
it's going to be a great game even
better if it's taking place in london
now let's talk about the labour party
what do you make of the way shakir
stammer has
handled the poor results obviously
outside london
for the labour party
i think the results were mixed across
the country we did well in london
in manchester in liverpool in wells
really good to see dan norris a friend
when i used to be an mp being elected
for the west of england the first time
we've won that seat
really could see us gaining a seat from
the tories in cambridge and peterborough
those mural elections really great to
see tracy brabin
the first ever mayor of west yorkshire
relieved
to finally stop seeing a decline of our
party in scotland but clearly
they were mixed and i think cair's right
to accelerate the progress we've got to
make
to win back the trust and confidence of
voters across the country his right to
do so he's our leader
and he should be supported in making
those changes i'm really pleased
that kear's not happy with the results
because they were a mixed bag
but demoting prominent women demoting
angela rainer demoting and lisa dodds
is that the right message
well hold on a sec angela rainer is one
of the best politicians we have she
needs to be speaking to the public
far more than she does as party chair
she's been brilliant on my campaign
uh my frustration is because she's part
of chair trying to sort out a party
she's not been doing more of that so i
think kei's right to get it in the front
speaking to listening and engaging with
voters she's brilliant
and rachel reeves will be the new shadow
chancellor
again she'll be able to use her
experience as a long-standing mp but
also anna lee is able to use her skills
as the as party cheers so it's really
good and also shabana
mahmoud a birmingham mp really good
experience
taking over the the party chair roller
as well so look i think there's an
exciting team that
that kier's got around him helping look
politics is a team sport
and those of us who are labor are on the
same side but we've got to realize
that tribal politics is gone
people vote for you on the basis of what
you have to offer it's more
transactional
and we've got to recognize that at the
moment in some seats across the country
we are at the races and care is
absolutely right
to accelerate uh the task ahead of us to
make sure
that we are ready when the general
elections called to make sure we win as
many
as we can i am fed up of being an
opposition nationally
the mayor of greater manchester said he
is available to lead the party
if called upon are you available to lead
the labour party have called upon
no uh kiss uh our leader kier is my
leader
he's doing a great job he has my full
support